Like right now. And right now,
the last conversation I had with Dr. Kevin Tracy,
it was in the board and for the jewelry, uh,
four Nobel prize winners or medical in the medical area.
He tested me in 2007 and he sold me influencing deeply into the
Vegas nerve and the Vegas nerve that is considered to be autonomy outside of
our will. Right?
If you are able to control or influence deeply into the Vegas nerve,
you are able to bring down inflammation,
which is cause and effect of disease.
We found the answers in nature.
Can you describe in any way that would be comprehensible to someone who didn't
know how to do it,
how you manage such things as control over the vagus nerve?
Yes, the vagus nerve and the autonomous nervous system,
the immune system and the endocrine system,
all those were thought to be out of our willful
patrol. And 2014,
I showed four as the first one in medical science to be able to be
injected and then have no sentence with equal light
bacteria, which can be lethal.
It's a strong bacteria and it causes
the cytokine storm.
Cytokine storm is inflammatory markers go and be Zurich within
our buddy because it doesn't not know what's happening and everything is in our
lab and it can damage our system.
That's a side to get stalk and we could not do that stuck.
And that day he tested me and I showed as the first one to be
injected and have no idea.
And so what did you do after you were injected to, to,
to stop doing things? Okay. I did two things. First of all,
I used my mind
and not just explained what the mind is capable of.
If it is connected to distress mechanisms, I will willful control.
Then you can give a neuro-psych know to the neurology
of the rest of the body to do whatever is necessary to,
uh, to, uh, neutralize physical impact of any kind.
That is, that is the real connection we possibly all have.
But I did that.
Then I used my will and I used breathing
and this breathing technique, apparently it's an amazing technique,
which has not known no way because I found it out by going into cold water
and cold water, you are directly
exposed to deep stress, freezing water, deep stress.
Are you buddy? What do you do? You don't think you do.
You learn to regulate biochemistry by deep breathing,
you jump into cold water and then you breathe the automatically like you,
like you demonstrated. And then you've,
you've played with that breathing and learned what I learned that
through deep breathing, I was able to prolong my,
stay into an cult water like tenfold.
How long did it take you?
How many months or years did it take you to only a couple of months,
a couple of months, couple of months. And I could stay,
I also did my breathing exercises and I could state
for five to seven minutes, breath, hold that's another thing.
And it's not sports. It's just,
our capacity is much more than we normally use. Right,
right in. You're making the,
you're making the case that if we expose our still ourselves to relatively
extreme stressors, that we become more integrated psychophysiological. Yes.